avancer si ce que je trouve
extraordinairement avec ce château c'est
qu'il ya tout il ya tout il ya quelque
chose qui intéresse qui peut intéresser
tout le monde
si vous êtes fans d'histoire
d'architecturé de la nature de qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire des formes de l'art de
la beauté du calme de la vie en famille
tout parce qu'on voit là derrière nous
se bouche à tous ces belles pierres mais
il ya aussi des beaux jardins
alors je sais pas si les jardins sont
très beaux mais ils sont très
intéressants parce que je suis en train
d'essayer de faire une conversion pour
arriver à faire plus avec moi plus
naturellement
en fait c'est tout ce que j'avais appris
quand j'étais enfant dans le jardin tout
ce qu'on peut faire pour réutiliser des
choses pour faire le planter des choses
mélanger et maintenant qui ça s'appelle
la permaculture donc là je peux y aller
franco
mais c'est encore mme pas encore au
point où j'aimerais au stade où
j'aimerais comment ça se passe vous
deviez vous obama quand il fait beau ça
se passe très très bien et quand il fait
froid on a froid on a vraiment très
froid voilà
il rentre
donc c'est des bâtiments qui sont dures
à entretenir qui coûte cher il faut être
fou pour essayer de les garder et c'est
pour ça que nous on est ouvert au public
et qu'on essaye de faire un maximum de
choses pour justement que le patrimoine
puisse être continué d'être mis en
valeur et de continuer date un dieu pour
pour animer en fait le pays où autour et
que les gens puissent toujours venir et
visiter ce beau lieu on voit qu'il ya
des enfants partout qui courent
ah oui moi j'aime beaucoup les enfants
et nous avons la chance d'avoir beaucoup
d'écoles qui apprécie beaucoup nos
visites et c'est quand même c'est un
lieu de mémoire de et de source
d'inspiration pour toutes les périodes
d'histoire et il y en a de tous pour les
écoles donc pour eux c'est vraiment bien
qu'ils puissent venir et nous on adapte
nos nos animations à ce qu' ils
recherchent